je vous rassure
reste ton calme je vous rassure madame
la ministre tu as pas grand chose qui me
fait peur mais je ne bois je ne vous
reproche absolument pas de faire des
constats ou des commentaires sur
l'échelle c'est parfaitement votre droit
comme c'est le mien
et j'en fais peu dommage mais en
revanche quand vous dites madame la
ministre
éventuellement je dis pas que vous
affirmer en 2025
l'arcome pourrait retirer
l'agrément je suis désolé de vous dire
retirer quand vous dites que l'arcom
pourrait retirer si cela continue
l'agrément aux chaînes en question vous
interférez avec les décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'art
comme pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à
partir de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de l'arcom
et moi Madame les ministres je serai
beaucoup plus intéressé par vous
entendre sur cette fameuse réforme de
l'audiovisuel public que nous attendons
depuis cinq ans je serais beaucoup plus
intéressé de vous entendre sur la
manière dont on va financer
l'audiovisuel public puisque depuis que
vous avez supprimé la redevance
audiovisuelle nous sommes dans le
non-dit et l'intérimaire alors madame la
ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez l'art comme faire son travail
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]